welcome everyone it gives me great
pleasure to invite you all on behalf of
the Terry lectureship committee to this
false Terry lectures in the true spirit
of the request to promote and foster
assimilation and interpretation building
upon the truths of science and
philosophy our speakers this year are
Joel Premack and Nancy Ellen Abrams who
will be talking to us broadly on the
cultural context of cosmology and will
offer insights into our place in the
cosmos what is unique about this year's
Terry lectures is that for the first
time we have two lecturers who happen to
be a husband and wife team comprising of
a scientist and a philosopher engaged in
a very vibrant innovative and creative
collaboration Joel Premack is professor
of physics at the University of
California at Santa Cruz he has been at
the forefront of research in the
formation and evolution of galaxies and
the nature of dark matter that makes up
most of the mass in the universe
starting out as a particle theorists
having made fundamental contributions to
what is now called the Standard Model of
particle physics professor Premack began
working in cosmology and became a leader
in the new field of particle
astrophysics he is one of the original
proposers of the theory of cold dark
matter which has become the basis for
the standard and modern picture of
structure formation in the universe
aside from his scientific contributions
joel has had an abiding interest in
science policy in particular on the
issue of nuclear disarmament he has
co-authored an influential book titled
advice and dissent with Frank Warren
hippo he was instrumental in setting up
the congressional science Fellows
Program Joel and Nancy were also part of
the official American delegation to
Moscow that helped negotiate the
decommissioning of nuclear reactors in
space with the former USSR Nancy
Abraham's read history and philosophy is
an undergraduate followed by a law
degree and further qualification in
international law finding the practice
of law to be somewhat restrictive Nancy
moved into the arena of science policy
she has long been interested in
the role of science and shaping politics
and has worked for the Ford Foundation
and the US Congress's office of
Technology Assessment she helped develop
a novel procedure scientific mediation
to help government agencies make wise
policy decisions in areas where the
relevant science is crucial yet rather
uncertain or controversial also
interested in science board sciences
border with myth Nancy Abrams has worked
as a scholar to place the discoveries of
modern cosmology into a cultural context
and as a writer and songwriter to
communicate their possible meanings at a
deeper level the 2010 Terry lectures
will also for the first time be a
multimedia presentation unlike anything
we've seen before including visually
stunning astronomical videos based on
real observations and cutting-edge
simulations of the invisible universe
from Joel's group set to Nancy's music
these calculations have been performed
with the state-of-the-art supercomputing
facilities in today's first lecture
titled the new universe Nancy and Joe
will explain the profound role of a
shared scientific understanding of the
universe with a strong sense of our
place in it we look forward eagerly to
this journey before we start I would
like to request all of you to turn off
your cell phones or beepers thank you
very much for that
thank you very much Priya that was
certainly one of the most eloquent
introductions we've had and certainly
the most stunningly well-dressed well
welcome everyone to this series of
lectures cosmic society and the first
talk which is the new universe in this
series of lectures we're going to do two
major things and they're going to be
intertwined the first is that will
present the new scientific picture of
the universe as visually as possible and
the second is that will interpret what
the discovery of this astonishing new
picture of the universe may mean for our
lives and discuss how we could help the
Earth's peoples become a cosmic society
that is a society whose members have
come to terms with their place in a
dynamic evolving universe and are
capable of thinking in and acting for
the very long term every culture that
anthropologists have studied has had a
cosmology meaning a story of how the
world began how humans came to exist and
the role of invisible forces in these
events usually spirits ancestors or gods
of course their notions of the universe
were not what anyone today would
consider scientifically accurate but
with what we've gained in this
scientific age we've also lost something
important we may be the first major
culture in human history to have no
coherent idea what our universe looks
like or how to think about how we fit
into the big picture in those high
places of human consciousness where
cosmic mythologies carried our ancestors
there is for our high-tech fast-paced
world just narrative darkness many
religious people still believe that
earth was created as is a few thousand
years ago while many scientifically
educated people think that Earth is just
a lonely rock in trackless space whose
right neither one both pictures are
wrong meanwhile our global problems are
accelerating religiously justified
violence exhaustion of play
Terry resources global overheating
economic chaos etc in these lectures
we're going to suggest that there's a
connection between our lack of a shared
cosmology and our increase in global
problems very few people realize this
because in modern life astronomy seems
to have very little relevance people
think of astronomical discoveries as
fodder for a news article that's fun to
skim perhaps or a great topic for five
minutes of dinner party banter but
frankly there's just no widely
understood connection between what's
happening in distant space and us right
here but the new cosmology actually
makes it possible at last to understand
how the universe fits together on all
size scales including our own the joke
among scientists used to be that
cosmology is the science where the ratio
of theory to data is nearly infinite
lots of theories almost no data but in
the last two decades this ratio has
completely flipped a flood of new data
has eliminated every theory but one and
that one not only fits all the data
increasingly it's predicting the results
of observations before the data comes in
the more we understand the theory the
better it fits the rapidly accumulating
data the technical name for this theory
is lambda CDM lambda for dark energy and
CDM for cold dark matter it tells us
that everything we can see with the
greatest telescopes on an orbiting Earth
is only half of one percent of what's
really out there the stars the glowing
gas clouds and this is one of the
pictures that just came down from Hubble
Space Telescope with the new camera wide
field camera 3 this shows the glowing
gas cloud and Carina in optical and
ultraviolet and this shows exactly the
same thing
but now in infrared and other capability
of this new camera so that you can see
through the dust that was obscuring
where new stars are forming so that and
also this wonderful new picture again
with wide field camera 3 of a planetary
nebula this picture of the planets
Saturn taken out near Saturn by the
Cassini spacecraft this actually shows
two planets hope you can see there's
earth seeing through Saturn's rings so
all of these pictures and also this
wonderful picture of the Hubble Ultra
Deep Field showing many many galaxies
out to the cosmic horizon all of these
images represent just half a percent of
what's actually there the universe as a
whole is controlled by two invisible
things whose tangle with each other has
created the galaxies and which are the
only the galaxies which are the only
home for the evolution of star systems
in life the two invisible substances are
dark matter and dark energy and it's
those together that are the basis of
this modern theory of how the universe
works and how it evolved the double dark
Theory dark matter and dark energy were
unknown and even unimaginative century
with dark matter collapsing the galaxies
into being and dark energy accelerating
them apart the evolving universe has
turned out to be far more dynamic than
the idea of empty space scattered with
stars and planets the end of the 20th
century in the beginning of the 21st has
been a golden age of astronomy and in
particular cosmology in a very real
sense we have discovered the universe
what is emerging from modern cosmology
is the first story of the nature and
origin of the universe that might
actually be true the difference between
our new scientific picture
and all earlier creation stories is that
the modern scientific story is supported
by an immense amount of evidence what's
more this is the first cosmology ever
created by collaboration of peoples from
different religions races and cultures
all around the world all of whose
contributions are subjected to the same
standards of verifiability the new
universe excludes no one and sees all
humans is equal there is a revolution in
scientific cosmology happening now that
may open the door to a believable
picture of the larger reality in which
earth our lives and all of our religions
are embedded this picture of the
universe could become the foundation of
a cosmic society now what exactly is a
picture of the universe here's an
example from ancient Egypt let's
simplify that just a little bit in this
picture the earth is flat and it's a god
named Gabe the heavens is his sister and
lover the goddess Newt they were born
locked together in an embrace and were
separated by the god shoe their father
who represented the air they longed to
come together again but she would hold
them apart and thus maintain the
creation only as long as the Egyptians
perform their rituals properly so
Egyptians felt that they were upholding
the cosmos literally and major spiritual
and ethical implications followed they
understood the everyday world as being
embedded within an awe-inspiring but
mostly invisible spiritual cosmos the
Nile for example flowed from the
spiritual world onto farms the lives of
the spiritual beings gave meaning to
life here the ancient Egyptians had a
rich and satisfying explanation of life
nature and the gods even though the
nature part was far from accurate by
modern standards now much later in
ancient Israel and Judah the three-part
flat earth cosmos was still unquestioned
but the parts were no longer gods as you
can see
but now they were inanimate earth air
and firmament for the Hebrews there
could be only one God but then came the
first great cosmological shift it
occurred when the ancient Greek
imagination burst out of this
effectively two dimensional flat land
earth of Genesis to the three
dimensional universe the Greeks realized
that Earth is not a pancake but a sphere
now by the Middle Ages educated people
from the Middle East and North Africa
across Europe all the way to Scandinavia
had come to believe that earth was a
sphere at the center of a spherical
universe everything revolved around the
earth nested crystal spheres carried the
moving planets and the outermost sphere
carried all the fixed stars the whole
universe rotated around Earth once a day
and outside the sphere of the stars with
heaven God had placed the spheres
exactly where they belong in a great
chain of being and the place of every
creature an institution on the earth was
part of this downward continuation of a
cosmic hierarchy thus it was considered
blasphemous to question the hierarchy or
the place God had chosen in it for you
this cosmology both explained and
enforced the social rigidity of the
medieval world but although it was wrong
astronomically that earth is the center
of the universe it was right
psychologically the universe must be
viewed from the inside from our Center
where we really are and not from some
perspective on the periphery or outside
in the medieval picture just as in the
egyptian picture the whole physical
world was surrounded by a spiritual
cosmos whose doings gave meaning to what
was going on here the second great
cosmological shift was the Copernican
revolution which began when Copernicus
proposed in 1543 that if the Sun rather
than the earth were seen as central it
would be easier to understand the
motions of the planets Galileo Kepler
and Newton completed the job and the
medieval picture of the universe was
placed by what we now refer to as the
Newtonian picture in the do tonian
picture earth is not the center of the
universe but moves like the other
planets orbiting our star the Sun in a
universe where no place is special or
central least of all ours this
intriguing drawing by Usher really gets
across the idea of space as an endless
grid where no place is any different
from any other there was no longer a
place where the physical became the
spiritual it was now physical all the
way out possibly to infinity this is the
universe that the great novelist D H
Lawrence once described as a dreary on
and on without any meaning with the
Newtonian picture of physical reality
dominant around them religious people
have often felt faced with a choice deny
the validity of science or accept it but
believe that there are two kinds of
reality the spiritual and the physical
with spiritual reality not constrained
by the laws of physics unfortunately in
such a dualistic reality it becomes
possible to believe in science and still
believe in almost anything else well we
who are alive today have an
extraordinary opportunity which as you
can see has only arisen twice before in
the history of Western civilization and
that's the opportunity to see reality of
fresh through a new picture of the
universe we are the first humans
privileged to see a face of the universe
that no earlier culture ever imagined
religious cosmologies like those of
Egypt in the Middle Ages may not have
been factually correct but they offered
guidance about how to live with a
feeling of belonging in the world modern
scientific cosmology says nothing about
human beings or how we should live or
feel it aims to provide scientific
accuracy not meaning or guidance but
today we really can't afford to see
these as separate anymore the human race
needs a believable picture of the
universe that includes all of us we need
to connect the two different
understandings of cosmology
into a science-based appreciation of our
human place in the modern universe let's
get oriented in the universe what is our
cosmic address this is a map of our
local neighborhood on progressively
larger scales it shows our so to speak
geographic place in the universe we're
going to use this to orient ourselves
first at the top our solar system where
we live on the third Rock from the Sun
earth each of the large shaded these
shows how the entire picture above is
just a tiny point in the much larger
scale picture immediately below so our
solar system is about halfway out in the
Milky Way galaxy it takes light about a
day to cross the entire solar system but
it takes light a hundred thousand years
to cross the visible part of the Milky
Way the Milky Way in turn is just a dot
on the scale of the local supercluster
of galaxies down here it's out here in
the boondocks in the video i'm about to
show we're going to go on a virtual
voyage from Earth past the local stars
out of the disk of the Milky Way and
then across our local supercluster to
the Virgo cluster of galaxies at its
centre the Virgo cluster is the densest
concentration of galaxies for a hundred
million light-years around the stars
that you'll see at the beginning of this
video were mapped little over 10 years
ago and the computer lets us move
through the stars and the telescopic
images of nearby objects we're going to
start facing this familiar constellation
Orion the Milky Way arcs to the left of
Orion
as we fly toward the sword hanging below
Orion's belt
the sword comes apart because all the
stars making up the sword or a different
distances we see that the center of the
sword is the Orion Nebula a gas cloud
illuminated by the young stars forming
there now as we pass the Horsehead
Nebula where 1,500 light-years from
Earth the next glowing gas tile that we
see is another stellar nursery the
rosette nebula
but not all these glowing nebulae are
stellar birth places this is a place
where a star died it was seen on earth
about a thousand years ago this is the
remnant of the crab supernova and you
can see the neutron star dat Center
blinking 30 times a second until now
we've been inside the disk of the Milky
Way where our view of the center is
blocked by dust created by explosions
like the Crab Nebula so let's rise up
and out of the disk so that we can see
the magnificent panorama of a galaxy
like our own as the galaxy recedes into
the distance with the large and small
Magellanic Clouds and other satellite
galaxies everything we see now is a
galaxy
let's now come into view is the great
galaxy in Andromeda and in the
foreground a smaller spiral galaxy
triangulum REM 33 as we go through this
glowing gas cloud in m33 where 2 million
light years from home our goal in this
voyage is the Virgo cluster just coming
into view on the left we're going to
take a scenic route pass some of the
prettiest nearby galaxies that can be
seen with an amateur telescope
now I hope you can see that there's a
chain of galaxies that ends here at the
Virgo cluster and in fact there are
several such chains of galaxies that
need at the Virgo cluster we're entering
this chain here in the Ursa Major group
of galaxies we're going to ride down it
toward the Virgo cluster before we were
seeing largely spiral galaxies but now
we're starting to see big balls of stars
elliptical galaxies this voyage ends at
this large elliptical galaxy at the
center of the Virgo cluster m87
astronomers call it there's a jet coming
out of the center and in the center
there's a gigantic black hole with the
mass three billion times the mass of our
Sun fast as it is the local supercluster
is just a tiny patch of the universe
there are many size scales in the
universe from bigger than galaxies to
trees and people to bacteria to atoms
and beyond how can we grasp them all we
hope that this graph will help and I'll
try to help you understand it by going
through it piece by piece first of all
remember that 10 to the 10 is one
followed by ten zeros that's 10 billion
and 10 to the minus 10 is a 10 billion
each of the tick marks on both axes are
separated by 10 billion by factor of 10
billion this is sighs this is mass or
energy one of sciences most essential
tasks is to rule out the impossible the
two slope lines represent the borders of
the possible
first the upper line is dictated by
Einstein's theory of gravity called
general relativity the relativity line
tells you for whatever size you choose
on the x-axis the maximum mass on the
y-axis that could possibly be packed
into it for example here is a neutron
star it's formed when at the end of its
life a massive star collapses a slightly
more violent collapse contracts that
neutron star so that it crosses the red
line and then it collapses a way to know
sighs at all according to general
relativity a black hole so general
relativity excludes this entire part of
the diagram the lower line in blue is
dictated by quantum mechanics the
uncertainty principle tells us that in
order to probe objects on smaller and
smaller scales more and more energy is
required represented by the vertical
axis of the diagram mass or energy
related by e equals MC squared thus the
region to the left of the white wedge of
material reality is excluded that means
that there's a smallest mass sorry
smallest length is what I meant to say
we can't conceptualize anything smaller
than the Planck length and our current
understanding of physics and here's why
the smaller the region the more energy
is required to locate something in it to
locate anything in a plonk size region
requires so much energy that the region
collapses into a black hole which would
instantly evaporate by Hawking radiation
and so the smallest size theoretically
possible is the plonk size about 10 to
the minus 33 centimeters it always helps
to know where humans fit in in the
middle of the diagram is the human scale
about a metre high or to meet
and about 10 to the 5th grams about 100
kilograms maybe a little bit less for
most of us the entire visible universe
is surrounded by our cosmic horizon so
that's the largest size that we can see
every place in the universe is the
center of its own cosmic horizon which
is determined by the age and expansion
history of the universe beyond the
cosmic horizon space is likely to be the
same as nearby with galaxies filled with
stars like our own but there's no way we
can know for sure because we can't
receive any direct information about
things beyond the horizon light cannot
reach us from any region out there now
that voyage that we took to the Virgo
cluster expand a distance of about 60
million light-years which is about 10 to
the 25th centimeters right here on this
diagram well not only is there a largest
in a smallest possible size but it turns
out that they may be connected so let's
lay a serpent along the x axis of the
wedge of material reality and we put the
tip of the tail of the serpent at the
Planck length and its head at the cosmic
horizon and now the serpent represents
all the possible size scales in the
visible universe but the serpent it
turns out is not lying flat like an x
axis it's actually swallowing its tail
so we call this the cosmic or Boris or a
Boris is a Greek word for tail
swallowing the cosmic or Boris
represents the universe as a continuity
of vastly different size scales about 60
orders of magnitude separate the very
smallest Planck length from the very
largest there's the Planck length and
the cosmic horizon at the head of the
serpent
now note that the human scale is right
in the middle so traveling clockwise
around the serpent from head to tail we
move down from a cosmic horizon to the
size of a supercluster of galaxies size
of a galaxy the distance to the Orion
Nebula the size of the solar system the
Sun the earth a mountain course we're
there in the middle an ant a single
bacterium a DNA molecule and Adam and
the nucleus of an atom the scale beyond
that of the weak interactions which are
carried by the W and Z particles and
approaching the tail the extremely small
size scales on which physicists hope to
find massive dark matter that's what the
DM stands for and I'm even smaller sizes
a grand unified theory that's the GU T
at the top the concept of size scales is
very useful not only for visualizing the
universe but for understanding ethics
and spirituality for our time but will
return to this the cosmic serpent
swallowing its tail which is a image due
to Sheldon Glashow the Nobel Prize
winner Harvard this represents the
possibility that gravity links the
largest and smallest scales and thereby
unifies the universe this actually
happens in superstring theory a
mathematically beautiful idea that
remains our best hope for a theory that
could unify quantum physics and
relativity in string theory sizes
smaller than the Planck length get
remapped and de sizes larger than the
Planck length so there's a connection
between the smallest and the largest
on different size scales different
physical forces control what happens
everything has to be the size it is it
could never work if there were any
substantial difference in size scale
models don't work like the real thing
size matters so on large scales gravity
controls on the size scales between
mountains and atoms it's the
electromagnetic forces electricity
magnetism the basis of chemistry on the
size scale of the atomic nucleus it's
the weak and strong interactions that
control along with electromagnetism now
we physicists have a very good theory
that fits all the data from accelerators
that includes the weak strong and
electromagnetic interactions this is the
so-called Standard Model of particle
physics but there's no room in the
standard model for most of the mass in
the universe Dark Matter so we think
that Dark Matter must correspond to
forces on scales smaller than the ones
we've talked about so far so dark matter
and then as I mentioned super strings
size matters this idea that size matters
was perhaps first understood by Galileo
and this illustration is from his last
book discourses and two new sciences
which he wrote under house arrest
Galileo explained that no animal could
be three times its normal height and
stayed the same shape simply scaled up
if the height increases by a factor of
three the strength of the bones if
they're if they retain the same shape
would just be proportional to their
cross-sectional area which would be
three times three or nine times stronger
but the weight of the animal would
increase with its volume and so it would
be 27 times greater and the bones only
nine times stronger could not support
the weight of such a heavy animal that's
why an elephant can't look like a large
gazelle the bones have to be much
thicker in proportion to their length do
you suppose Hollywood understands that
and here's another example now shrinking
smaller
everything has to be the size it is or
it doesn't work right these familiar
films illustrate the popular
misunderstanding that things work the
same way no matter how much bigger or
smaller than normal they are so what's
our place we humans are exactly or
almost exactly at the center of all
possible sizes and this is true here we
are whether the units used are
centimeters nanometers or light years so
it's not an anthropocentric bias if we
use different units the only difference
is the numbers in the exponents we would
still be Central and we couldn't be
anywhere else if we were much smaller we
wouldn't be made of enough atoms to have
the kind of complex consciousness that
we have if we were much larger the speed
of thought and other internal
communications which are ultimately
limited by the speed of light would be
too slow it's really only near the
center of possible sizes that
consciousness like ours can arise and
this tells us something about
intelligent aliens if they exist because
anywhere in the universe they'll have to
be approximately our size now that
doesn't mean five or six feet tall that
means somewhere between a redwood tree
and a puppy that's actually a very
narrow sliver of possibilities so here
we are at the center of the cosmocorps
Oh Boris and the size scales surrounding
us make up our conscious world which we
have attempted to show here in sunlight
it includes everything from the littlest
creatures that humans can see with the
naked eye smaller than ants preps and
adds up to about the size of the sun and
this section is what most people think
of as reality but as you can see it's
not all of reality it's just a very
special part of the universe for which
we humans have awareness and intuition
this is our homeland in the universe so
Joel and I decided that we would give a
name to this very special group of size
skills and we call it Midgard in the Old
Norse cosmology Midgard was the human
world it was an island representing
stability and civilized society in the
middle
of the world see which was the Norse
universe the world see was large and
there was room in it not only for
Midgard but for the land of the giants
and the land of the gods this is an
excellent description metaphorically of
course of Midgard in the expanding
universe our Midgard is the island of
size scales that are familiar and
comprehensible to human beings but
beyond the shores of Midgard in one
direction outward into the expanding
world see is the land of
incomprehensibly giant beings like black
holes a million times the mass of the
Sun or galaxies made of hundreds of
billions of stars in the other direction
from Midgard inward toward the small
lies a living cellular world and beyond
that the quantum world and these micro
lands are the evolutionary and physical
sources of everything we are that may
not make them gods but compared to us
they're more prolific more ancient
Universal and omnipresent like the
north's Midgard our Midgard is not
isolated from these other lands in the
world see it's connected as the cosmic
Ouroboros illustrates Midgard is
everywhere in the universe it's not a
place it's actually a setting of the
intellectual zoom lens so if you travel
to a planet for example in a distant
galaxy a billion light-years away and
try to get around your mid garden
tuition would be very useful although of
course fallible but if you stay right
here in this room and just change your
mental focus to think about size scales
outside Midgard in either direction
large or small you find that your
intuition becomes worthless without
science no one can and no one ever did
imagine accurately how very small or
very large things actually behave until
the 20th century infinity was thought of
as an endless extension of Midgard
that's the way Isaac Newton picture the
universe but now we know that once you
jump off the island of Midgard nothing
is the same the very laws of physics
that control events change with
exponential increases or decreases in
size scale physicists may think that the
word physical means anything described
by the laws of physics but to most
people physical means solid observable
unquestionably here physical is
intuitive concept not a scientific one
only in Midgard two objects satisfy
people's intuitive sense of what's
physical why does this matter because
many people assume that a spiritual
reality exists as Nancy said earlier it
is separate from the physical universe
it transcends the universe and therefore
does not obey the laws of physics at
least it doesn't have to but the concept
of Midgard undermines this belief not by
telling us anything about the spiritual
but by making clearer what the word
physical means to most people the
largest structures inside the cosmic
horizon superclusters of galaxies are
actually expanding apart faster and
faster and in billions of years they'll
disperse they're not bound together by
gravity but by our top connecting Minds
so in some sense they're not really
physical objects in the opposite
direction of Midgard toward the very
small there are elementary particles
that are not particles like marbles but
rather quantum mechanical objects that
are routinely in two or more places at
once the strange truth is that what we
usually think of as physical as a
property of Midgard perhaps the defining
property unless Midgard is what most
people think of as physical beyond
Midgard however lies most of the cosmic
Ouroboros most of the physical universe
much of it is not physical in the common
sense meaning of the word but it is
nevertheless real and governed by the
laws of physics transcendence is not
some kind of jump to a reality beyond
the universe as if that even meant
anything transcendence is what happens
within our universe every few powers of
ten for example on the atomic and the
subatomic scales human means nothing
there's no humanists to our atoms
whether atoms are inside us inside a
rock or drifting through space it's all
the same to them we conscious beings
understand that atomic behavior is
fundamental to what we are
but on the atomic size scale even inside
our own bodies we as we think of
ourselves we do not exist a human being
transcends the world of atomic
interactions we are qualitatively
completely different although completely
consistent each size scale is in
seamless continuity with the next and
yet every few powers of ten wham there's
a qualitative difference a new
phenomenon like temperature or
consciousness comes into being or
hitherto irrelevant law of physics takes
control choppiness in the way complexity
grows is characteristic of the entire
cosmic Ouroboros and so qualitative
change every few powers of ten is a
universal pattern as the physicist Phil
Anderson says more is different so let's
take a fast trip now through all of the
size scales that it's possible to
visualize from bigger than superclusters
down to the size of smaller than the
atomic nucleus and notice that there's
going to be an arrow pointing to the
size scale on the cosmic aura Boris that
you're seeing at that moment
good or a Boris thinking give us a new
way of understanding ourselves
exponential growth happens not only in
sizes but also in the complexity of
human interactions everyone has probably
noticed that although individuals can be
kind generous and wise people
collectively in the form of a committee
a city or a country are almost never
kind generous or wise even though the
individuals who make those groups may be
a recent newspaper headline I saw said
do the banks have no shame no banks
can't have shame a collective cannot in
principle feel or act like a human being
because it's not human even though it's
made of humans this may be hard to
believe at first but think of it this
way you are all made of elementary
particles but you don't behave anything
like an elementary particle remember you
transcend them we humans are the most
complicated things we know of in the
universe every one of us has multiple
roles on all these size scales we have
our own self-consciousness we have an
identity as part of a family as part of
our tribe or community part of our
religion or nationality part of the
human species life earth and we are also
part of the self-consciousness of the
cosmos
our sense of identity of who and what we
truly are expands breathtakingly the
moment we realize that we are all these
things with our new understanding of the
cosmic Ouroboros that different laws
control events on different size scales
we can begin to bring our consciousness
of our full selves our potential and our
responsibilities into harmony with
universal reality the left side of this
human identity or ab oris represents the
traditional layers of consciousness that
we humans have developed through
cultural evolution but we're not
finished you will notice a gap between
the religious and nationalistic
identities on the one hand and species
identity on the other how can we get
across this gap how will we jump from
traditional narrow identities that are
endlessly in conflict with each other to
a science-based identity that tells us
that it's far more important that we are
human beings then that we are part of
any smaller subgroup modern biology has
discovered that all humans are more
closely related to each other
genetically then are the members of any
other species on the planet in
scientific cosmology the challenge is to
move out of Midgard but for expanding
our human identity the challenge is to
move into this central area because it
represents the crossover from subspecies
identity two species identity from
traditional religious cosmologies to a
science-based appreciation of our true
place in the universe the jump two
species identity is a qualitative jump
of course we have to keep expanding our
consciousness to recognize our even
larger identities as the consciousness
of Earth and the cosmos but these will
follow much more easily once we have
accepted that we humans are all in this
together in the Bible Jacob has a dream
in which there's a ladder from Earth to
heaven and angels are moving up and down
the ladder and here are two beautiful
traditional interpretations of that idea
by William Blake and Marc Chagall
but in the modern universe the real
Jacob's Ladder is the cosmic or a Boris
and the angels going up and down are our
own educated consciousnesses each of us
can play all of our roles only if we
adjust our consciousness to think in the
appropriate way on each size scale that
is if we move up and down the ladder
this may sound obvious but it is
anything but most people are still
thinking about global politics or
economics with understandings moral
judgments and above all a sense of time
that are appropriate only two much
smaller size scales like a family or
community a year a single lifetime they
have no way of comprehending the
thousands or even tens of thousands of
years that things we are doing to our
planet might last the oceans are already
destined to rise for a thousand years
because of global warming even if human
beings all around the world completely
stopped putting greenhouse gases into
the atmosphere tomorrow radioactive
waste could be dangerous for a hundred
thousand years extinction is four ever
the science of cosmology aims only to
understand the underlying principles and
the history of the universe not to
change people's lives and not to
challenge their religions but once we
find out about these principles they
necessarily change our thinking we
realize that we are governed by them and
so is everything that's what Universal
truly means a cosmic society needs a
cosmology that's based on science but
gives us some guidance about how to live
every traditional ethical system teaches
how to get along with other individuals
in the tribe but now modern leaders both
political and corporate control events
on enormous time and size scales that no
religious political or other tradition
has ever even contemplated big changes
in ethics are required for decisions on
these scales the principle of the cosmic
Ouroboros
help us understand how groups of us can
collaborate respectfully and
productively with outside groups on all
relevant sighs skills no religion
teaches how to do this at least not yet
there are invaluable benefits available
to people who claim they're accurate and
rightful place in the universe and
adjust their thinking accordingly to
feel your roots stretching back through
cosmic time is to know who you are and
to see from a cosmic perspective these
are two abilities that our species needs
to cultivate far more widely if we want
to protect the chances for our
descendants over the cosmologically long
time in lectures three and four next
week we will come to the question of how
to live in the new universe the answer
will be based not only on the new
understanding of size but on the
subjects we're going to cover in the
next lectures the nature of time what
the universe is mostly made of how it
began how we came to be here and how we
can create stories about these things
that are powerful and bonding as well as
accurate science is the foundation but
discovering and expressing its mythic
meaning will be essential if it's going
to have any real impact on our lives we
created cosmic society not by zipping
around the cosmos but by expanding our
thinking right here in the lecture
tomorrow we will concentrate on the rear
stuff we humans are made of compared to
the rest of the universe and the role of
time and letting these ingredients
interact one of the main things that we
hope to explain is that we're special or
central in fundamental ways our bodies
are midway between the largest and
smallest possible sizes we are made of
the rarest material in the universe
heavy elements Stardust here's some
Stardust that's a type 1a supernova
explosion we like all observers are at
the center of our visible universe
and in the third lecture will explain
that we're living at the midpoint of
time in four different senses we hope to
see you back tomorrow for lecture 2 and
let me tell you that if you enjoyed the
videos this lecture you have a real
treat coming next lecture there are I
think eight major videos in next lecture
thank